it's not difficult is it Angelica I mean
that is what a woman is I mean I don't
know why you're obsessed with defining
it like what what is a man like why do
we need these arbit a man is a male
adult human I mean that's it right okay
I don't know that we need these are just
biological facts but they're just facts
they're not they're not arguable points
are they but you I think we have a right
to self-identify and you say want to if
you would like to be a woman you can
identify as a woman I don't know why
there is such an issue around we've
literally just seen a male rapist use
that scam to get himself put into a
female prison where he could attack
vulnerable women inside a female prison
when even his ex-wife said it was all a
scam which is a terrible very
distressing isolated incident and I
think it's easy to take that and say
that means that no no no one can
identify as a woman not an isolated
incident though but it it's 42% of of
trans identifying prisoners in prison
are in there for sex crimes there is
actually an advantage evidently to
identifying as a female because they
never identify as male because somehow
male prison seem less appealing to them
it's really weird anyway but is it is it
is it Limitless this self identity it's
not totally Limitless so when when
you're talking about International
women's day I don't know why we take the
the conversation around International
women's day and make it about this so
many Ben but if anyone according to you
can identify as a woman anyone can right
I don't see a problem with just
literally put the hand up and say I'm a
woman but it's not an easy thing to do
to go out into the world very easy easy
you might think it's easy to say but to
decide to do that to say involve
whatever that person decides but to go
out into the world and say I I don't
identify as perhaps the sex so why can't
I identify okay why can't I identify as
a black
lesbian well firstly I mean it I'm
serious I'm serious if I can identify as
anything without any need to prove I'm
actually what that is why can't I on
International wom they say I'm Pi Morgan
I'm a black lesbian I think taking it to
a kind of absurd status
talk about with respect I think that
you'd already opened the absurdity door
by saying it is Limitless you can do
what you like anyone can say I'm a woman
so I simply ask you why can't I I mean
this point kind of ridicules trans
people to an except actually I think
what you said ridicul trans people
because actually people who who go
through the full process of transition
who actually go through what we used to
call a sex change which I don't think
you can Muck around with original
biology but those who actually go
through surgical procedure of a number
of years I've got great respect for that
very difficult Journey they go on I have
zero respect for people who just Wallop
their hand up and go suddenly I'm a
woman and I want all the rights that a
woman has and I want to compete say in
sport I'm a 6' 4 in athlete Sprinter
swimmer whatever who's competed very
mediocrely in male Sport and I want to
come in and Crush women in swimming
pools and in sprinting events and break
all their records perhaps irrevocably
just by by saying I'm a woman I think
that is the absurdity you were talking
about no but can you imagine you coming
to our restaurants and and then you get
some people coming to your table and
trying to disrupt your evening it's it's
abuse I'm going to start I am going to
start running into vegan restaurants
that's fine go being annoying grabbing
tables and so you can't eat your gr and
just see how you look like it I'm going
to go to your house and chop paint all
over it you've got a right to oh you've
got me another one take off your bingo
fastic your where's the salt where's
where's it won't need any of this gr put
that to one side but I will have a bit
of steak just to you didn't Sal it
though you see all you've achieved is
you've made me want to do this just
that's absolutely
fine you go for
[Music]
it you know do you know how many steaks
he's had from my restaurant yeah a lot a
lot a lot but here's my point I love
eating steak I'm not going to stop
eating steak and the the very last thing
on Earth that will stop eating steak is
people like you with your pasty faces
running into our restaurants telling us
to stop eating Stak we took LGB and then
we added lgbtq I A++ plus and then we
included men who dress up like women and
mock women like influencer Dylan Mulaney
and then a lot of American conservatives
just said listen we've had enough it's
okay if you're proud of your sexuality
but why do I have to be proud of your
sexuality that's where you lost a lot of
folks and we're starting to finally
first say trans woman Dylan is a woman
so you got that wrong and secondly Dylan
was Dylan was a gay man until last year
Dyan was a gay man until last year
they've transitioned they a woman I
think that we lost people right at the
beginning when gay people were dying in
the streets because no one was looking
out for us so actually what we're doing
right now is just I wouldn't even use
the word celebrating I think pride is a
protest has it is it a bit too much in
other words do you want to what does
that mean what is too much in other
words I think with every campaign
bringing people with you is really
important right the moment it looks like
it's just over the top like it's
everywhere you go it's pride pride pride
pride pride do we need to be that
exuberant about are you blaming gay
people for that I mean thought the
compan I don't honestly I don't care
what sexuality anybody is I don't think
most people do anymore right so what is
the problem then why are you so
triggered by a flag a rainbow flag you
mention Regent I'm not triggered by flag
I'm triggered by the fact that
everywhere I go for a gallender month
everything has to be a rainbow flag well
I'm triggered that everywhere I go for
the entire year everything has to be
straight where is it why is straight
where's my Straight flag why am I
constantly my Straight flag why straight
people holding hands in the when have
you ever seen a straight flag why is
Mickey Mouse got tell me one straight
flag hanging right now anywhere in the
world why are straight people Ping
Identity where the straight flag
everywhere where's my Straight flag it's
everywhere it's never been a straight
flag you're a straight
flag if you don't mind me ask you how
much do you weigh
look I'm not going to talk about numbers
because the thing is when you you should
no the thing is if I give you the number
of how much I weigh it's going to be all
over the sun all those trashy newspapers
tomorrow morning I don't need it don't
need it you don't need it you're on
you're on Tik Tok every day showing this
how big you are yeah and look and you're
proud of it no no no no no no there's a
difference there's proud and then
there's just being positive in my own
skin and that's what I am right I'm not
I'm not I'm not proud to be fat would
would you accept that by medical
definition you are morbidly obese look
if that's what medically you want to
call it then call it you know your
weight I don't no no no but that's yeah
you could say that yeah right so here's
my issue with this body positivity thing
people shouldn't be celebrating being
morbidly obese in my estimation that's
the because actually it is a dangerous
condition that causes many people to die
look you've got a fair point it is
dangerous it can lead to dangerous
issues which could you know diabetes and
so on and that is an issue but we don't
encourage gaining weight there's a
different between the videos you just
showed on the screen what we're
now no no no you're you're showing
people encouraging eating food I'm just
saying wow look at the pizza look it's
from Costco it's nice no you're not
you're not sorry you are glorifying
ginging it's called taking a piss that's
what it is maybe that's what it is it's
having a laugh and not taking yourself
too seriously why is it funny because it
is funny you know it is funny you had a
little smoke yourself before I actually
don't find this kind of funny I think
come on I actually think it's quite sad
it's not sad it's comedy let me bring
it's satire comedy you know it is you
know it is you know it is p I've been an
actor for 13 years you know damn right
now this industry Works let's bring in
RZ he's chuckling away because you find
all this terribly amusing uh RZ you
supported just doop oil uh no one at
Wimbledon today supports just St oil
they just think you're a bunch of idiots
I know you weren't there today you were
shouting at the Royals up in Scotland
why do you support this kind of protest
that we're seeing at all the sporting
events
oh I'm not sure I've completely condoned
that and to be clear I'm not speaking on
behalf of Republic today I speak on
behalf of no more Royals but absolutely
we are protesting in Scotland and Pier
you're going to like you've just been
going on at these guys that just up oil
about why are you disrupting Ordinary
People and why don't you target the
right thing and we've been doing that uh
shouting at the king why do you support
that method of protesting why don't you
come out and condemn just opil like
Trevor neelon who was funding some of
this stuff before has suddenly realized
the Penny's dropped it doesn't
work uh I'd like to talk about
coronation because it's but uh to
respond to that question uh we're in a
climate crisis is horrifying I'm
terrified for my future and just the oil
are one of the only uh groups of people
at the moment who are doing anything
about that uh but as I say I'd like to
focus on the issue well I'm sure you
would I'd like to focus on what's just
happened because it's indicative of of a
summer of protest by people who think
they can convert people to their cause
even if people are inclined to do so
we're now at a point where you can tell
from the audience reactions at these
events they literally want to grot them
and what worries me is it's going to
lead it is going to lead to bad
situations if this carries on because
people are going just just going to take
the law into their own
hands uh sorry that's stupid sorry I I
swearing
you want to talk about the
protest you don't have to you want to
talk about the protest or do you want to
say uh that protest shouldn't happen and
we should all suck it up and deal with
it CU that's easy for you right like
you've been dealt with pretty good hands
I believe in peaceful protest but I
actually care I believe in peaceful
protest do you want to talk about the
peaceful protest I believe in peaceful
protest I don't believe in Wrecking
ordinary people's lives is they going to
work is they going to hospital as they
on some OCC cases going to funerals I
don't think that when they pay for
sporting events that they maybe saved
money for all year
long did that today i' love they
shouldn't have it ruined by a bunch of
let's talk about it there was a republic
up at one end who were uh a massive
crowd far bigger than any of the
monarchist I mean the streets are pretty
much empty uh I haven't had a chance yet
to look at any of the coverage but I
think you'll see that because uh there
is pretty much nothing going on on the
monist end and the Republic demo is
enormous uh and then there's no more
Royals who did a banner drop uh uh
chanting can I swear I just did uh the
king feed the hungry because that's what
we want to talk about right uh you know
what you know for they they've done this
you know what is for a bright young
woman who's getting a very good
expensive education you do behave like a
complete foulmouthed idiot you don't do
yourself any favors why do you think
coming on a show like this and just
repeatedly using the FW why do you think
that makes you look any better yeah I
did apologize for that iiz for that in
advance but was what we said three times
yeah uh F the king yeah I'm I'm happy to
censor it it's not an invalid argument I
meia that there you know in All Sport
you're going to get some people who are
physical freaks if for one of a better
pH like Michael Phelps who literally
could do this and it's normally the same
as your height or something isn't it the
span and he had six inches extra and
massive hands right obviously can help
him and huge feet I think as well what's
what's your response to that argument
but biologically they're still the sex
that they're competing against
um you know at the end of the day
reducing a testosterone level is is not
going to cut it because women are so
much more than a testosterone level you
know phys physiologically you know
periods whole other whole other disc
that is certainly not to be you like
it's we're so much more than a
testosterone level so just reducing a
testosterone level at the end of the day
I mean it's not going to change the
physiological differences a lot of these
people too are you know they're training
as a male athlete for long period of
time before transitioning so they're
having capacity as well all these things
which you get after you know having gone
through puberty they're real things
which give most most trans athletes a an
immediate biological advantage that's my
problem the other half of this is what
what if if they don't compete against
women born to female bodies what happens
to trans athletes now I think there's
one of two things you can do either they
compete against their biological sex
which most of them have done anyway for
many years actually never as
successfully as they do when they
compete against women which I think is
the argument right there or you create
an entirely new category there are more
and more as you said at Grassroots level
you create an entirely new category for
Trans athletes to compete against other
trans athletes well my starting point is
there shouldn't be a blanket ban on all
trans athletes there should be
individual assessment so where issues
rais that's never going to work is it no
of course it can you can't make it one
you know person by person by person by
person you can't there are not that many
trans athletes overall and it's quite Fe
actually there are more and more of them
well there are but there's still a very
there already 13 in Elite Athletics DSD
athletes the 13 Elite see what my issue
with is they're going to start breaking
women's records irrevocably because I
mean Leah Thomas won One race against
females that's just a point of the
argument females are 50 odd seconds I
mean it was ridiculous and then the
podium Towers over these these this
Podium picture you can't no one can be
happy about that yeah that is clear
Advantage for a biological male you as a
woman how comfortable do you feel about
someone who until last year was a gay
man of 25 suddenly without any surgery
starts doing Tik Tok videos saying I'm
now into Womanhood and I'm a girl on a
journey to girl to being a girl and then
does a Nike have for sports bras for
women despite not having any breasts and
more importantly mocks the way women
women do sport if you look at it as a
misogynist that's ridiculous not that is
ridiculous she's not mocking the way
that we Sport and also can I just say
that was really rude from your other
guest I don't know what her name is but
Dylan she's a she I don't understand why
you'd need to open up your commentary
with that you're obviously appealing to
a certain R she would like to identify
now as a she yeah just just leave her
alone but until last year she was a he
but importantly then she was a non hang
on a a AA it's complicated keeping ask a
question I know but it's complicated
keeping up with these people like Sam
Smith who was a gay man then he was
non-binary then he was gender fluid now
I have no idea what he is other than he
dresses up like Satan half the time um I
don't know what Dyan malban really is
other than a lot of women particularly
in America have taken great exception to
the way Dylan malany mocks women female
Behavior because they believe that Dylan
malany is a biological man listen the
anti-trans movement in America is very
different to what it is in Britain in
Britain feminists claim that it's
because they're worried about men
invading their spaces fine whatever in
America it's a concern conservative
movement and it's because they don't
believe that these like that trans women
fit into society and it's all out of
this pent up Christian aggression that
is quite disgusting this is where you're
wrong look I I I hate I hate how you've
opened up this debate and asked me if I
find it offensive as a woman or whatever
I don't care I don't care that Dylan
doesn't have breasts and wear sports in
the same way that women had double
mastectomies because of breast cancer
don't wear you know they wear a sports
bra as well it doesn't bother me what's
in people's pants or in people's you
know bras no I'm not preoccupied with
that I'm do you care that Leah Thomas a
6'4 inch biological male who competed
unsuccessfully as a man at swimming is
now winning National Championship
swimming races against biological
females I think that's extrapolating the
argument care because what we're talking
and whether she's on a beer can we're
talking we're talking about the whole
trans issue my argument to you is do you
care about that is she a woman huh in my
opinion she's a woman so she compete
that's fine what give him the voice for
all of our
community complet hypocrite let me bring
me bring James back in Morgan is
agreeing with you I think you need to be
concerned I'll say that for the so
you're telling a dwarf after to what he
should feel having hang on having
literally just lectured me about
speaking for someone in the dwarf
Community War Davis you now accuse a
dwarf act not no it's not what I said I
said that if anyone if you're signing
with anyone you've got to worry what I'd
like to say actually is that I kind of
mostly agree with what you're saying and
sir that's just taking a pot shot there
by saying it is absolutely taking a pot
shot but I do agree with what you're
saying I completely agree with your
point of view and I think that's really
important but I I can only speak from my
experience and as a gay man I know that
growing up I witnessed gay people being
villains in movies when I was seven
dwarves aren't villains and that I think
stereotypes are really important to
stere in the universe of Snow White
wouldn't it be better dwar feel
this isn't a part of the about The
Stereotype right this is about roles
that were that were made for people such
of my stature that don't have the chance
to go out for other roles normally but
you James you want to stop Dylan getting
a role in a Hollywood I'm not going to
get into an attack on a dwar you don't
want a dwarf actor to land the role a
dwarf part listen a dwarf can play a
dwarf part but I think it's important to
change narratives that don't fit in
today's society and really it might
better it might be better if dwars just
exist in normal roles everywhere because
they do exist so bad about the way
dwares were depicted in Snow White have
I missed something well that listen I'm
not here talk that's what that's what
I'm kind of wondering I don't represent
Disney but I'm just saying I think I see
their point of view what's their point
of view what was so bad about the
depiction of the why are you so upset
about a movie changing with the times
and moving forward because I think
honestly with great there is real news
we could be discussing no but this is
real news if you're a dwarf actor who
are now out of work because of virtue
signaling idiots who think that
everything has to be Rewritten to be
inclusive in it's not inclusive at all
no you're using Dylan as a cheap shot to
attack a woki that's I don't think Dylan
feels I'm using him as a cheap shot and
what I would say about the woki thing is
this I have spent the last year
listening to people tell me only gay
actors should play gay Parts only wellsh
actors to Michael Sheen should play
Welsh characters and so on and so on and
the moment we have dwarf rols which are
the most famous dwarf rols in Hollywood
history then the only people apparently
you can't play them are dwarf actors and
I see there stinking hypocrisy well
jayen Cheney made Global headlines this
weekend after claiming fat people are
entitled to extra seats on planes
because they're so fat she said all
plus-sized passengers should be provided
with an extra free seat or even two or
three seats depending on their size to
accommodate their needs and ensure their
comfort during the
flight well look jayen you can have your
extra seat you can have 10 extra seats
you've got to pay for them why should
you be entitled to special treatment
raising the cost of travel for everybody
else because you're obese maximum self-
entitlement zero self- accountability
free seats for fat Flyers Esther the
idea that the more obese you get the
fatter you become the more free seats
you're entitled to on a plane it's
ridiculous well I mean the the lady in
the video who was saying it she was
probably the size of the plane that she
wanted to fly look the reality is we've
always seen you know debates online
about whether you know if you need a
seat Bel extension you should really buy
two seats because you're spilling over
into the other person p and seat and
airplanes are designed to basically tin
you like sardines right so the idea that
someone else should pay for the fact
that she's obese is is quite frankly
ludicrous reality exists biology is real
and is that reality legal one because in
this country is is a legal reality zubie
that you can change your gender you
cannot change your biological sex it's
physically impossible I'm I'm saying to
you legal reality you can can you change
biological sex we can talk about biology
and we can talk about the legality we're
talking about biology though we're talk
this thing is about sport this is about
males and females well the problem when
we talk about biology is neither us a
scientists but you scien you and I both
know that it's a lot more complicated
that it's not as simple as for me it's
very simple for you it may be very
simple but we are I think we're being
we're indulging and ignorant by not
suggesting it than that can you become
male I don't want to be can you become
male is is there anything that could be
done that could turn you into a male in
the way that I'm a male and Piers is a
male is that is that possible see now do
you see how you've qualified your
question so you first ask me can I can I
can I be can I become a male and I would
suggest probably yes in terms of
medically but then then you said then
you said then you said like you and PE
and that's where we start to get compens
PA I hoped we would have taken you a
little further down your journey I feel
when you say when you say you think you
can become male you can't because male
is a sex I can have a I can have a g I
can have gender recognition can't I I
can legally become a male we've got to
leave it there but you can't actually
become a biological male and nor can I
can I you'll be relieved to hear become
a biological female because I'm quite
tempted right now to start entering the
cricket competition right and smashing
female biological Bowlers all over the
place and feeling good about myself only
I wouldn't I'd feel ashamed I think
it's